sicles you can watch this and other
programs online at book tv.org
good afternoon I'm Mariana Hersh and I'm
the director of the institutes for
research on women gender and sexuality
and it's a great pleasure and great
honor to be here this afternoon to
moderate this panel and really the
celebration of a wonderful new book
webblock the perils of marriage equality
by our own wonderful Katherine Frankie
what we're gonna do this afternoon is
have some presentations and responses to
the book and then open up for questions
and discussion and we have assembled a
stellar panel of the people who are just
the right people to undertake this
discussion and I'm going to introduce
them all briefly all together and then
they will speak in the order that we've
determined but it's gonna all begin with
a presentation a brief presentation of
the book and its main issues its history
by Katherine Frankie and Katherine
Frankie's the Isidore and civil suits
praça professor of law she's the
director of the Center for gender and
sexuality law which is a wonderful
institution that we're so happy to
collaborate with at the earwigs and
she's the author of wedlock the perils
of marriage equality NYU press 2015 just
recently out Katherine's been working on
marriage on queer theory on gender
justice on transitional justice on
gender and issues of gender and race in
law she's a legal theorist she's an
academic she's an activist she's a
public intellectual and she's just an
amazing human being so I'm so happy to
be celebrating her this afternoon our
speakers will go in this order we're
first gonna have Patricia Williams who
is the James door professor of law at
Columbia she's the author of alchemy of
race and rights of the Roosters egg of
seeing a colorblind future the blind
goddess and you know net no doubt know
her through her monthly column for the
Nation magazine
entire diary of a mad law professor
which you can subscribe to at wwm a law
professor at WordPress
our second speaker will be minion Moore
who is associate professor of sociology
at Barnard College and who co-directs
the Resource Center for minority aging
research at the UCLA School of Medicine
her research examines the intersections
of race gender class and sexual
orientation and her recently her first
book is invisible families gay
identities relationships and motherhood
among black gay women it was published
in 2011 by the University of California
Press and was the winner of the 2013
outstanding book award by the American
socio a sociological association section
on sex and gender she's working on a
second book project entitled the shadow
of sexuality social histories and social
support among african-american LGBT
elders looking forward to it and our
third speaker Kendall Thomas is the Nash
professor of law and the director of the
Center for the Study of law and culture
which he co-founded with Kathryn Frankie
Kendall Thomas is the co-editor of
critical race theory the key writings
that founded the movement and also
co-editor of what's left of theory with
Judith Butler and john guillory
his most recent writing and research has
focused on the law and culture of death
penalty politics racial democracy in
Brazil and the law and politics of
racial neoliberalism in and after the
Obama presidency so please help me
welcome first Katherine Frankie
[Applause]
thank you so much I'm gonna move this so
that we can all see one another I teach
in a room like this and manipulate these
things frequently so along with my
students so here's the book
very exciting thank you thank you all
for coming it's just so wonderful to
have you come out and honor honor this
work and and honor thinking about
marriage in a in a complicated way and I
know so many of you do that in your own
work and your own politics in your own
lives so I appreciate having company
because the kinds of perspectives I have
on marriage equality are not always the
most popular within the gay community so
you are my community right now thank you
and thank you to ear wax and iris for
co-sponsoring this event along with my
own Center the Center for gender and
sexuality law when I was in college at
Barnard College I went to college across
the way here sodomy was a crime in New
York State and in many other states but
I I moved here from Illinois to a state
that criminalized who I was or at least
things I did and twice while I was a
student at Barnard I was assaulted by
police and they hurled homophobic
epithets at me and another time I was
beaten up by some guys over here in
Riverside Park and police stood by and
watched so for people in my generation
or certainly for me the idea that not a
lot later we would turn to state
regulation as a way to be freer and more
equal people struck me as a strange move
and it still strikes me as a strange
move that it that not many years after
our intimate lives were criminalized by
the state and we
we were prosecuted for it both publicly
and privately and that's what I take
we're bashing to be as private
prosecution that that we would invite
the state into our intimate
relationships and ask the state to
regulate them that is always struck me
as an odd political objective and I
thought I'd write a book about it and so
that's that's what wedlock is but I also
thought that gay people or same-sex
couples are not alone in that experience
of having the state regulate their lives
in the form of marriage
shortly after or as part of a civil
rights movement or a movement about
emancipation of the people and so I turn
to what African Americans went through
or actually they weren't even African
Americans at the time because they were
not citizens but what black people in
this country went through at the during
and after the Civil War when they could
marry for the first time and I thought
maybe there's something interesting to
learn from that experience as we have
turned in the gay community to marriage
now as a form of liberty and equality
and and it turns out there is quite a
bit we can learn and that is what this
book does is it offers each at chapter
offers parables for today's movement not
to equate homophobia and racism is the
same thing not to say that the
experience of violence and dispossession
and and torture and enslavement that
black people have suffered in this
country is the same thing as what gay
people have suffered and formed various
forms of homophobia but to create what
Edward Sayid describes as a
juxtaposition between two movements so
that as we formulate our goals
articulate our values and and pursue our
political projects today we do so
mindful of other movements that we are
juxtaposed with and who can teach us
those movements can teach us something
about both the possibilities and the
perils of certain political and legal
claims and so and so that's what the
book aims to do is bring these two
movements together these
moments together to see what lies there
in it and it turns out that marriage
equality does indeed have a racial
history it also has a racial present and
that is one of the take-home points of
of this book is not only be careful what
you wish for but that the the
distinctions the differences between
homophobia and racism the difference
between marriage equality today and
marriage equality in the nineteenth
century for newly freed people point out
something about the racial endowment
that today's marriage equality movement
has enjoyed and the ways in which
marriage has been an enormous ly
successful method by which to rebrand
homosexuality as I say in wedlock to
take the sex out of homosexuality and to
redeem gay people and particularly
certain gay couples who are able to be
respectable and seem entitled make a
plausible claim of entitlement to the
blessings of marriage and in doing so
they contrast themselves to those who
are deserving of exile from the
institution of marriage who were
deserving of social judgment and social
stigma and almost always those are
people of color in this country and so
this juxtaposition helps us understand I
think how unfortunately some of what
we've won in the marriage equality
movement has been a kind of zero-sum
politics or zero-sum rights where gay
people and some same-sex couples have
won a right to marry at the expense of
others both implicitly and explicitly in
the arguments that have been made in the
marriage equality cases so let me just
say a little bit about what a couple of
the chapters do in terms of be careful
what you wish for marriage and rights in
particular can become a form of
discipline and particularly a form of
discipline when when many sectors of the
society still hates you and that was
certainly true for newly freed people at
the end of the war it's not that the
abolition of slavery abolished racism
racism took new forms or persisted in in
old and familiar forms and being able to
marry for the first time inaugurated in
a way a new regulatory relationship and
a new disciplinary relationship for
black people with the state and so when
black people coming out of enslavement
who live together as husband and wife
were automatically married by operation
of law unwittingly in many cases and
then their relationships broke up which
you know in any population that's going
to be the case and people took up with
new partners mostly black men were
prosecuted for bigamy or adultery which
was a felony meant which meant they
would lose their right to vote which
would put them in prison and render them
subject to the convict leasing system
that was developed after the end of the
civil war so that because there was this
body of workers that were available to
do the agricultural work that enslaved
people had done before the convict
leasing system was more deadly for black
men than was agricultural work while
enslaved so marriage rights and
particularly the law of marriage of
divorce or see the law of divorce and
the law of monogamy around bear on brown
marriage ended up giving the state a new
power to discipline punish and sometimes
kill black men just at this moment when
they were freed from the crushing
effects of slavery and the crushing
reality of slavery part of this was a
civilizing mission and I think we see
this today as well that of course
there's an enormous backlash against
there was an enormous backlash against
African Americans or black people at the
end of the war and there's a backlash
against same-sex marriage rights now
mostly done under taking in the name of
religion but not only and so to the
extent that we've had smooth sailing
today on the rights of same-sex couples
to marry it has been local in many
contexts and in certain many parts of
the of the country marriage rights are
not something that people feel they can
exercise because they don't feel free to
come out
and they know that there'll be
retaliation against them but they're
they experience or metabolize that fear
against a backdrop of this message from
both people in the gay community and
outside the gay community who say that
being married will civilize you it will
tame those wild sort of lascivious urges
of gay men who don't know how to sign up
for one another and commit and be
monogamous and we heard a very same
thing about African Americans at the end
of the war that they would have somehow
had savage sexualities that needed to be
disciplined through the institution of
marriage so that the civilizing
Institute aspects of marriage the values
it carries as its own portfolio
sometimes overwhelm the values of the
communities that seek to exercise these
rights and the book tries to to answer
that as well or to address those
questions one other place where I think
there's a similarity or at least a
particularly compelling lesson to learn
from the historical connection is about
how a right to marry can collapse into a
compulsion to marry or requite not on
the level of my kin there are some
people go around and marry in every
state they have a kind of diagnostic
problem of over marrying there's not
that kind of compulsion I mean but the
state will compel you to marry and so in
the 19th century we we saw even before
the end of the civil war in order for
fleeing slaves slaves to who were
leaving
the plantations to the safety of
northern troops who set up refugee camps
around the military operations that they
were conducting in the south a minister
was placed at the gate of many of these
they called them contraband camps but
but refugee camps and you could not gain
entry into these camps without marrying
that was seen as the most pressing
problem was that these posts were coming
in and complicated families because but
of course people had lost their spouses
and their children as their owners had
sold them away and these families were
reassembling and coming to the safety of
these refugee camps and the north
northern soldiers and missionaries that
were running them said well we can't let
you in and those de botched families
we're going to marry you at the game so
the right to marry turned into a
compulsion to marry in many contexts and
we see that today as well not just
generally but here at Columbia
University right as soon as in New York
State we gained the right for same-sex
couples to marry the University a
polished it's domestic partner benefits
and said you have a year to marry your
partner and if you don't they'll be
kicked off the health plan shocking that
a secular University what get in the
business of promoting and enforcing
marriage and thanks to the organizing of
a bunch of us here at the University we
got them to reverse that policy but not
for different sex couples and the
president had promised that they would
actually keep domestic partner benefits
for both same and different sex couples
because in New York City our domestic
partnership law recognizes both same and
different sex couples
but they only reinstated domestic
partner benefits for same-sex couples so
actually now the university
discriminates against straight people
gay people are paid more our same-sex
couples are paid more in the sense that
you can get benefits for your partner
whether or not you marry them but if
you're if you're a heterosexual or if
you have a different sex partner you
have to get married so so these are some
of the difficult questions that I think
have come up in history around marriage
and around how marriage ends up
overwhelming the politics of a larger
movement that might have wanted to
recognize more complex families both for
African Americans and for queer people
or gay gay and lesbian people today and
we've lost queer families as kind of the
subject of gay rights in the same way
that we fought for them 10-15 years ago
many of us who were early advocates
working on issues of LGBT or queer
family rights saw marriage as is
actually a problem it was a sexist
institution written to sir
legally concretize to preserve property
and usually male property and and and
creating viable life outside marriage
was our political project and something
happened something happened and and the
movement got overtaken by by marriage
politics so one last thing I want to
offer and that I just would love to hear
from my colleagues although I feel kind
of badly that were racially segregated
up here the tables is i-i've never
talked publicly about this but when I
was in college here at Barnard I was
sort of coming awakening as many
undergraduate students do to being a
lesbian although it those days I didn't
use that word I could describe myself as
gay and I was reading May Sartain as a
lot of us did now she was a poet and a
novelist and a memoirist who was very
well known in the 70s and 80s and she
wrote a journal called a journal of a
solitude that was just very moving and
important for for me and for many of my
friends and I as I was coming out I
thought I'm gonna be lonely when I'm
alone when I'm old and and may Sartain
was old at least to me at that point and
she wrote about being old and alone and
I worried that the only way to not be
alone when you were old is to be married
and I really didn't want to be
heterosexual and I really didn't want to
be married so I wrote her a long letter
and she wrote me back so here's what she
wrote me I'm not gonna read you the
whole letter it's typed it's this like
old-fashioned you know typing over that
so she said you imply that what you want
is love as a sideline and solitude as
the main current I don't see this as
possible for love without commitment is
pretty cheap this is where marriage
comes in
I read you was terribly afraid of being
caught and people who marry simply
because they want marriage do often find
themselves caught it looks to me as
though you have never loved a man enough
to want to marry him which which was
true
yeah and it's as simple as that when you
do and I hope you will there won't be
any argument and then wouldn't you want
children she goes on to discuss how
lonely the life of the unmarried person
will be and she hopes that I won't be
that person so let me just quote quickly
from Justice Kennedy in the obergefell
decision which is the decision from the
Supreme Court recognizing a
constitutional right for same-sex
couples to marry among the things he
says is this marriage responds to the
universal fear that a lonely person
might call out only to find no one there
it offers the hope of companionship and
understanding and assurance that while
both still live there will be someone to
care for the other really and that there
is no life other than just dark
loneliness if you're unmarried and this
is the price of unfortunately of winning
the right to marry is that life outside
of marriage whether you choose it or you
find yourself there and for complicated
reasons is a grim lonely dark life
that's not a queer value in my mind and
I think we can look to the
african-american community to see
enormous resilience creativity and
flourishing in life outside marriage so
thank you so much
[Applause]
oh it's so wonderful to be part of this
conversation thank you so much for
inviting me and congratulations
Katherine wherever you are this book is
really the most interesting Pharaoh
excavation of this history imaginable
and comparative study between the two
efforts for marriage equality
comparative study aside the case studies
in your book are absolutely fascinating
totally absorb absorbing and quite
revelatory of the life circumstances of
enslaved men and women in or out of
marriage and one of the things that I
was most impressed with in these
intervals and stories was the malleable
line between intimacy and the
untouchable and the question you raised
in the subtitle is one of the perils of
marriage equality the question of
whether it is marriage that does all the
work one might want to assign to it in a
comparative sense to the marriage
equality for gays I think we'll probably
be addressed more thoroughly than I by
me Nolan Kendall so I'm going to narrow
my reflections to a much smaller set of
observations and that really is because
my and you know for those of you who've
read anything that I've written I'd
write constantly about my line I mean I
am here because my
great-great-grandmother was married off
by the wife of the slave owner
she chose who the light-skinned women
among the house servants should marry
for the saving I think ultimately of her
own marriage and so it's Katherine notes
in in in some of these stories I think
that it is that what I want to note here
is that marriage among African Americans
really did affect and I mean effect in
the affective sense the institution of
marriage among whites as Katherine notes
in several of the histories a
significant number of slave marriages
were overseen shall we say by owners by
the Masters and another dimension of
that history is the degree to which much
of that permission to marry came about
not so much through the male owners of
property but through the civilizing
uplift
and ever so self-interested
administration's of the wives of those
owners and slaveholders and that
prompting of the union of slaves to some
degree operates like any other marriage
it makes public an exclusivity of
intimacy and to some degree it
eliminates the dangerousness as well as
the perversions of sexuality but
marriage among African Americans both
Antebellum and at least until the loving
case in 1967 is a double-edged thing
purifying respectability making but also
underscoring the dangerous
untouchability of black sexual bodies
those first African American marriages
were a ritual after all performed
against the backdrop of the breeding
farms that Katherine talks about in the
book and the mysteriously light-skinned
house servants and unnameable acts of
incest disguised as the production of
inventory rather than progenitor to say
nothing of primogeniture it was and
still is a ritual prompted perhaps most
particularly unjustified most poignant
ly as a way of formally corralling the
unregulated boundless resource of black
sex of sex with black bodies so all this
is really interesting to me as a kind of
formal genuflecting toward the repair of
threatened white family reading white
womens histories of the time there was
something to be said about how if
marriage left african-americans freed
but not free it did something of the
same thing for slave holding families
particularly the women in that it had at
least as much to do with reinforcing not
just the legal but the moral status of
terrified white wives the sexual acid
nations that have only recently begun to
be publicized or acknowledged from
Annette gordon-reed history of Thomas
Jefferson all the way through Strom
Thurmond's daughter by his maid this is
a traumatic history a family of
unmarriageable family even as the
salutary properties of the institution
were applied to a cultural landscape
torn
scarred-up ended by the unspeakable and
so marriage operated and continues to in
this double sense as the pathway to
salvation but as a skeet sealant against
the leakage of miscegenation so again I
think this effective dimension is
accompanied by all the dodges and faints
marked in the words we use and don't use
even to this day I'm struck by how in
today's world the benefits of marriage
among African Americans and the status
it confers is very peculiar when it
comes to African Americans not so much
when they marry but when they marry
outside the race or transgress what are
perceived as racial boundaries just
think of the use of the word biracial it
is a kind of formal recognition of a
certain line of descent that is not
accorded to those who are just the
product of being tossed around in the
back of those slave cabins there is a
legitimacy accorded to the lineage the
recent lineage in particular of
intermarriage formal marriage between
blacks and whites in modern times that
the the children of whom will be called
biracial if for only a temporary period
that is to say when they get out of the
presence of that one black and one white
parent it is a kind again of recognition
a legitimacy accorded to the lineage of
the white or non black parent that one
doesn't otherwise mark in our vocabulary
and I think it was a kind of comfort to
white ears for example when Obama first
came upon the scene to speak of him as
biracial he has a white mother and he
loved her so he won't be a big nudge
about race like that noisy Al Sharpton
or somesuch but as he's been normalized
and by that I mean really stereotyped
and made unexceptional he's just another
black man I mean he always was but there
is a shift in nomenclature for some
particularly among those who don't like
him so marriage among or with African
Americans has this extra burden of
operating to simultaneously proclaim and
deny the rambunctiousness
of our lineage the language by which we
assign the benefits of marriage use uses
racial category to narrow or expand our
perception of who is more like whom
tells us who can be
considered marriage Abel or untouchable
our habit of burying the relentlessly
promiscuous nature of our American
identity renders us blind to how
intimately we are tied as kin his family
and his intimates again consider SEMA
Williams Washington Washington Williams
the daughter of United States Senator
Strom Thurmond the one he had by his
family's black maid notice how Essie Mae
Washington Williams has no mark of
Thurmond in that lengthy name she also
lived her life as a [ __ ] ken attended
an all-black college but in her 70s when
Thurman's fraternity became publicized
she was suddenly redesignate in the
media as by racial even with that
designation
she was always referred to as a child by
his maid I never I have not been able to
find any reference to her as his child
or take Tiger Woods and Kimora Lee
Simmons who are alternatively thought of
as african-american or biracial but
rarely as asian-american so there is
something unspoken and indicative about
African descent and its dangers in
American society this kind of vocabulary
nods to both again the intimacy and the
untouchability the sight the smell of
black bodies the aesthetics of beauty
and desire marriage is only one site
where one can remark upon this anxiety
the effective nature of racial boundary
and it's constructed perverse
transgressions are all about sympathy
and sympathizers an associational
contagion after all in the antebellum
period the retribution Catherine
describes as being rained down upon the
left-behind wives and children of freed
soldiers extended not only to those
wives and children but to anyone deemed
sympathetic this was an assault on human
sympathy that leaves its traces to these
to this day from the use of the term
[ __ ] lovers during the civil rights
movement to some of the very interesting
locations used to address mayor of de
Blasio and empathizers of the hashtag
black black lives matter movement
Elizabeth Rudin osco describes
perversion as thus it uses the speech of
the subject but only to mimic the nature
from which it has been extirpated so as
to parody it all the more
that is why perverse discourse is always
based on a mannequin ISM that appears to
exclude the dark side to which it owes
its existence and to me it is that
affective dimension that leaves its
trace through all the cases in
Catherine's wonderful and intriguing
book
[Applause]
hello I've had some laryngitis so just
bear with me as has been stated thus far
in different ways
Katherine Frank's exciting and superbly
written new book
we´d locked the perils of marriage
equality looks at the role of marriage
and liberation movements for formerly
enslaved people and for same-sex couples
she asks what kind of freedom and what
kind of equality does the capacity to
marry actually mobilize the book reveals
that gaining rights can bring about
disadvantage in other ways particularly
when the group in question does not have
full equality she states quote a closer
look at the history of marriage among
African Americans and the newly won
rights of same-sex couples illuminate
how gaining marriage rights can come at
the price of stigmatizing other groups
and ways of life on marriages outside as
a family sociologist who focuses on the
intersections of race class gender and
sexuality I was particularly interested
in thinking about how the ideas in this
book play out with people's lives today
particularly those who are experiencing
the after-effects of the marriage
equality movement sociologists we like
to talk about we like to ask questions
like to talk to people and we like to
use this data as one basis for
evaluating information what if anything
do we gain by using marriage as the
platform for reducing stigma associated
with same-sex desire so I'd like to
consider this question as it relates to
a population who stands at the juncture
of the two seemingly disparate groups
Kathryn uses in her arguments people who
are black and gay throughout the text
the persistent overlap between the
categories of white and gay versus
african-american and deviant subtly
strength and race and class inequalities
because each dimension of inequality is
light legitimacy by its alignment with
the other so I'm going to respond to
some of the arguments and Katherine's
but by considering the enero
seas that were not present there which
are the experiences of these
african-american LGBT people and the
interracial relationships among blacks
as they relate to the marriage equality
campaign so for the past 12 years or so
I've been in focused on the
intersections of race and LGBT sexuality
through such concepts as identity
motherhood race consciousness racial
group commitments and various other
aspects of life and meaning making among
black same gender loving people I see
marriage equality as a public issue that
has provided a vehicle through which
sexual minorities who also have a
membership in a racial or ethnic or
cultural category can develop a
conversation about their sexuality with
family members and others in their
communities the use of marriage equality
as a representation of LGBT rights has
helped move gays sexuality from the
private sphere as a behavior that
individuals act out in secret and under
a cover of shame or secondary status to
one that initiates a public openness
about who members of these identity
groups are and provides a voice around
those who have multiple identity
statuses now there are there are other
issues that are important to sexual
minority populations that we could have
used in this campaign LGBT homelessness
and foster youth face unique challenges
as research by Bianca Wilson at the
Williams Institute shows we could have
used employment discrimination that's
another another relevant topic and
access to quality health care is an
important issue particularly for trans
folks and with sexual minority elders so
why marriage well Kathryn argues that in
the minds of larger society quote
marriage has been and largely remains a
kind of test that the African American
community is seen as failing in my first
reading of the material I was somewhat
put off by this and other statements
like it feeling like it does a
disservice to those couples who have in
are succeeding at marriage it ignores
the advantages that blacks who marry
actually gained in society or the
special status that married people of
any race or ethnicity receive and it
removes any
agency or self empowerment from
african-americans by only presenting the
ways that some groups pathologize all
blacks regardless of marital status and
I know this was not the intention I know
that the intention was to call awareness
to the structural racism that vilifies
African Americans a vilification that
they or we cannot seem to get away from
no matter what our actual behaviors are
and I do think that she does present
that argument also in the book so I find
that for African American groups in
particular the topic of marriage is
particularly relevant as a point of
entry into discussions of LGBT identity
and acceptance in that it serves as a
physical response to this stigma that's
often associated with the wider range of
family structures among blacks the
stereotypes of men who fail to hold up
to their responsibilities the
stereotypes of black women is sexually
permissive beings to a morally choose
single motherhood over the stability of
a marital Union weddings in black
community symbolized the attempt of the
couple to conform to notions of
respectability and to shelter their
families and others in society that they
defy these negative stereotypes and that
they can create these stable families so
marriage offers a conventional and some
might say conformist presentation of
self an antithesis to the images of gay
counterculture but because of the
racialized context in which same-sex
marriage among African Americans is
taking place for that community it
becomes a radical and transformative act
I've spoken with couples who say that in
having a wedding they're removing the
ability of their parents to engage and
don't-ask don't-tell with themselves and
their partners by drawing a line in the
sand they're risking rejection and
disappointment from adult siblings or a
favorite uncle
that wedding lights the pastor in the
church they grew up and no affirmative
leader yes they have taken on this
quote/unquote lifestyle and they're
going to openly live with the mate and
many who have a religious wedding
service actually have the audacity to
want their God to recognize and bless
their union so anyone who said has any
knowledge of black religious communities
can see the radical nature of this
supposedly conformist behavior
so I'm not trying to take away from the
beautiful and persuasive arguments that
Katherine makes in what locked regarding
this critical view of marriage as a
force in social movements that are about
liberation I don't disagree with that
but I'm saying that it's precisely
because marriage holds such an important
ideological position in the minds and
experiences of so many different groups
that it is a useful and important
frontier the marriage equality movement
is useful in a way that is separate from
the question of the kind of equality the
capacity to marry might actually
mobilize wedlock also critiques the LGBT
movement for the overwhelming whiteness
that characterized much of the campaign
particularly among the time of the 2008
political debates but between that 2008
election and the 2013 Supreme Court
decision
I witnessed the shift in the way LGBT
organizations tried to quote-unquote
sell the country on marriage equality my
wife and I Elaine we were married in
2012 shortly after New York recognized
same-sex unions and we're one of those
crazy couples who got married a lot we
got married three times that year we've
been together for 10 years so I guess we
had to go all out when we finally
decided to commit to it and and once our
wedding pictures were published we were
approached by Evan Wolfson Evan Wilson's
Freedom to Marry Campaign and through
that experience I saw a genuine effort
to expand the representation of same-sex
couples in the in the public eye so they
were images of older couples of folks in
the south and mid mountain regions of
the country latina women
african-american men even some
conservative religious couples and as a
result of that work several different
things happen for us we were on the
cover of Black Enterprise magazine where
this conservative business magazine for
for black business minded people so I
say this as an aside to show the ways
the movement recognized and tried to
rectify some of its prior mistakes and
the way those images we use not just in
LGBT organizations but then other groups
and outlets as the Supreme Court case
move forward now wedlocke argues that
marriage with same-sex couples quote
both reflects and Denver
reproduces a new form of respectability
soul yearned for in many sectors of the
gay community
she says removing the marriage band
removes the quote marriage badge of
inferiority for whites in a way that it
does not and cannot do for blacks
because of race while I agree I also see
important class differences in the
extent to which blacks experience this
disadvantage so in some ways the the
book crosses an imaginary line when it
only depicts marriage as quote a site of
failure and dysfunction for many
african-americans because I see where
middle and upper-middle class
african-americans are able to benefit
from many of the advantages and
legitimacy that marriage brings their
class status grants them certain
privileges and this is true even in
religious communities I recently
interviewed Rahim an African American
gay man he lives in a large southern
city with his husband and their two
adopted children and he was raised in a
holiness Pentecostal church which is a
conservative denomination he is a
graduate degree he works for a biotech
company his husband's a pastor of a
church that keeps traditional
Pentecostal beliefs but it's welcoming
to everyone including LGBT people they
live in a grand house and together they
bring in six-figure income and I like to
say it's a six-figure income that does
not start with a 1 or 2 so when I asked
how he and his family were faring in
this conservative state in the South he
told me his only experience in an
enormous amount of love and support even
from those who quote might not support
the LGBT community he said that when he
walked around with his daughter and a
baby carrier even when he was with his
husband in the South black people have
said to him that rarely have they seen
black men so actively involved in
raising their young children they say
this is not the norm in their experience
with men so here the comparison group
for the community has not been a
heterosexual couple meaning are the
children worse off being raised by gay
men instead of a married man and woman
but absent black fathers look at these
men they're very present and involved in
their children's lives and that is a
good thing and they appear very well-off
and isn't that great for the children as
well so this is one area where racial
texts and the communities experience
around black men and families sets up a
dynamic that may not have even been
considered in debates and discussions
about gay men raising children it was
also clear that his money was able to
buy his family out of the negative
experiences that are others report
although wedlock argues that
african-americans have not been able to
use marriage to quote rebuild rebrand
blackness in the way that sanitizes
racist stereotypes this Blake black
couple has been able to at least silence
or protect themselves from the harm
affiliated by those stereotypes and I
can think of other heterosexual black
couples who are similarly situated who
use this status as income this education
to shield themselves but I will say
again institutional racism rears its
head from time to time to interject
itself into their lives they cannot
escape that their money cannot escape
that racism and I suspect that this
truth is that is at the heart of
Katherine's argument but it appears as
though the drag of two subordinated
status is based in race and sexual
orientation do not affect their lives on
a daily basis so what LGBT communities
who are African Americans say about
marriage equality as this vehicle to
liberation well I see two primary
responses this past spring the Institute
for Research on African American studies
here at Columbia had a panel in Harlem
about the meaning of marriage equality
for African Americans and Darnell Moore
was on that panel for those of you who
don't know Darnell he's a brilliant
african-american writer and activist who
does many things including advocating
for LGBT youth in Newark and he said
that he came from a low-income family
where people did not marry women raised
children with the help of their mothers
and sisters the relationships they had
with men were for different reasons
fleeting or short-term they were mainly
worried about how to survive so marriage
was not a priority and it influenced his
own lukewarm feelings for marriage he
said there were other pressing needs in
the population that he works with like
having a safe place to live and those
kind of things so for his remarks I say
that this focus on marriage equality
they may not be useful particularly to
those who are under door
socioeconomically disadvantaged so in
this sense Catherines argument is right
even for the intra-racial case and that
marriage equality cannot be the only
story that the movement brings to
disenfranchised communities they have to
also show that they care about and
realize the importance of other issues
of bread-and-butter issues poverty
unemployment racial profiling inferior
grocery stores inadequate services but
other black GP LGBT leaders have looked
past the specific example of marriage
equality and music is a tool to promote
greater understanding and acceptance
interracially within the group so
they're trying to think of how to
maintain and build relationships and how
to stand proud and openly express this
gay identity that's simultaneous with
the racial identity and so one expressed
goal for the work is to challenge and
conquer their own homophobia in addition
to working to change the minds of the
racial group they want to build the
group self self acceptance of their own
sexual orientation by D stigmatizing and
transforming the meaning of gay
sexuality and my last comment I'm just
about I want to say that the potential
there's a potential that I see for
same-sex couples to radicalize marriage
because of the lack of sex differences
between partners and the greater
equality that comes from it there are
differences that can exist in gender
presentation but those do not translate
to gender inequality the gender
inequality that a century of
sociological literature has found in
heterosexual relationships through men's
advantages in the labor force and other
social institutions simply put some
women may dress in a boyish fashion but
they lack men's institutional power and
do not and cannot assume a hegemonic
masculinity instead couples are making
decisions on how to lead their lives
based on other factors besides sex and
the power distribution in these
relationships are not based in gender
and they're not even based in who has
the greater economic power so I see the
potential for these relationships that
create something different within the
state of marriage and I say this even
while agreeing with wedlock's assertion
that
the institution of marriage was and
still is structured around gender roles
and inequalities my time is up so I'll
stop here but I want to say that you
know despite my sociological
interpretation I really really enjoyed
this book and I enjoyed the arguments
that have had with folks but I also
enjoy the premise the very premise of
the the pitfalls to using the law in
this way so I do appreciate that and I
thank you for your time
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone I apologize in
advance for my voice I don't know if
I've caught what Mino has but I'm going
to give it a go
I've always thought that the best
scholarly work is scholarly work whose
lines of inquiry of analysis and of
argument give rise to more questions
than the author of the work can possibly
undertake not to address or answer there
is a lot to say about this wonderful
book I do hope that we have a chance for
a more extended conversation than the
hour 90 minutes or so that we've set
aside this afternoon will allow so in
that spirit I want to use my allotted
time to say a bit about four panels that
I think would make a wonderful
conference program on this extraordinary
new book by my dear colleague Katherine
Frankie
the first panel would be a panel on
method and it suggested to me by this
formulation a formulation which we see
in a number of places in the book but
I'll quote it here
Katherine writes at one point that the
book central conceit associates two eras
and two civil rights movements with one
another what she doesn't say but which I
think ought to be stressed here is that
the book central project also associates
two methods wedlock brings together the
preoccupations and procedures of two
critical of two critical perspectives
one critical race theory and the second
queer legal theory in a kind of hybrid
thought style whose modes of inquiry and
analysis challenged the assumptive
structure of approaches that take race
sex and sexuality and gender I might add
as separate identities and a siloed
experiences I've always liked Rachel's
image of
the categorical miscegenation of sex and
sexuality and gender and race and
ethnicity as a way of trying to
understand this this analytic
methodological hybridity right so child
suggested race sexuality gender race and
ethnicity are coterminous and enmeshed
in ways that an optic which is rooted in
intersectionality the idea that two or
more separate identities or experiences
meet in a particular place I think only
helps us partially apprehend Catherines
calling instead for a connection
analysis
she calls it associative following
Edward Sayid and it's an analysis which
is alert to similarities and differences
to convergence and divergence to
continuities and discontinuities as
catherine suggests for Frankie the
obvious fact that race and sexuality
ought not as some would have us believe
preclude a careful investigation of both
race and sexuality and of how they come
to be what they are in part precisely
through their difference right so this
is the old post-structuralist chestnut
of identity indifference and the book
gives us a very concrete on the ground
and extended elaboration of the
importance of holding on to both of the
chains at once put another way race and
sexuality and gender are different but
they move and live and have their being
in and through and around one another
wedlock reminds us that this attention
to identities as they are shaped and as
they take shape in and through
difference is a crucial resource for
making sense of what civil marriage
means and of the work it does at the
current conjoined the current
conjuncture for gay and lesbian people
as well as for people of color whatever
their gen
or sexuality conceptually this means I
think tracking the movements and
manifestations here with respect to the
law and politics of marriage of race as
sexuality and of sexuality as race
sexuality is raced we might say I have
said that and race is sexualized right
sexuality is a technology of racial
power and race is a technology of sexual
power as we know for example from the
work on the idea of sexual racism right
so Katherine Frankie's account of gay
and lesbian marriage as a story that is
closely connected not only closely
connected to but as a story about race I
think represents an enormous ly valuable
contribution to the work of those who
are situated at the intersection of
critical race theory on one side and
queer legal theory on the other and she
does it through this idea of aggregation
she's calling an effect one might say
for an aggregation of race and sexuality
which recalls in a kind of reverse
mirror image an argument in her earlier
work against the disaggregation of sex
and gender so this attention to and her
delight in the thought experiment that
is possible when one engages in a kind
of free association historically
informed to be sure but a free
association of sex and gender offers us
a rich analytic a tool for tracking most
shifting and supple and fluid moment
movement of marriage law across multiple
multidimensional axes the book allows us
then to think in fractal terms one might
say about the condensations the
combinations and the recombinations the
dynamic fluid character the mixed moral
character of marriage law a feature of
marriage law that is central to the
stories that she tells both about
african-americans in the postbellum
period and about gay men and lesbians so
this allows us to see the normatively
white character of the marriage equality
movement even when the arguments at
least in legal terms weren't explicit
and the heteronormativity a fancy word
which I will use with the shout out to
its use earlier this season in Empire
all marriage equality law so my central
point here is that wedlock stages an
encounter if you will of CRT and queer
legal theory that allows us to
understand in the words of my friend the
scholar WA Nimal obiano the places where
race no longer talks about race
precisely and paradoxically by talking
about it through something else and
elsewhere what asked slew beyond oh my
race help us think about that race does
not name but to which it is nonetheless
connected in my own work I've suggested
that one of the things race helps us
think about is sexualities Catherine
shows us in wedlock that one of the
things that thinking about gay and
lesbian sexuality helps us think about
indeed demands that we think about is
race what might be called race - sex or
sex race in a fusion that I think
represents an important insight about
how to understand this moment in the
history of marriage equality law and
politics the second panel would be a
panel about law as a structure of
feeling it would focus on those aspects
of a marriage equality debate which are
about the emotional and the sensit about
physical and psychic if you will bodies
and the term bodies here is central for
me Katherine at one moment in the book
talks about going through these archives
in the South and finding
locks of hair and finding pieces of
quilts that people sent along with their
petitions for widows benefits and seeing
the smudges of fingerprints on the
papers that people who couldn't sign
their names but wrote X left when they
when they were writing to the government
seeking war widows benefits this
attention to structures of feeling to
use Raymond Williams phrase or as I put
it here to the body I think offers us an
insight into what marriage equality law
is doing that bears directly on a second
point that Catherine makes which i think
is absolutely crucial
she asks more than once how it is rights
bearing subjects are almost inevitably
shaped by the rights they bear she
framed it this afternoon in her own
remarks as the the moral lesson to be
careful what you wish for right how is
it that rights bearing subjects are
almost inevitably shaped by the rights
they bear shaped in ways that show how
rights and freedom are only contingently
related that is how the benefits of
rights may come at the cost or the price
of certain kinds of freedom for
Catherine this is a paradox I think it's
important as I said to identify and
describe this paradox but I think we
also need and this is what my ideal
panel would do we need to try to explain
and understand it so the question would
be what drove the marriage rights
movement so willingly into the arms of
the law what was the consideration that
led gay men and lesbians to enter into
what might be called a marriage contract
not just with one another but into a
marriage contract with the state now
Catherine suggests that gaining the
rights and marry has marked a kind of
emancipation from the
burdens of social objection for gays and
lesbians first in that the marriage
license mark marriage license marks a
kind of social belonging and recognition
of equivalents and second because it
serves as a kind of credential that
vouches for the legitimacy and quality
of the couples relationship but over and
above these utilitarian features of
marriage that make it something gay men
and lesbians have come to want our other
non utilitarian dimensions that can only
be rendered visible if we understand the
freedom to marry as being not only about
the right of gay men and lesbians to
marry one another but about the right if
I can put it this way to marry the law
to marry the state right what marriage
equality law has done catherine says is
to radically refigure the meaning of
homosexuality by recrop ting gayness
around status or stable identity rather
than sexual acts so we see an opposition
here between identity sexual identity
and sexual acts but I would ask though
to what extent we still need to see
marriage equality law as a body of sex
law what do I mean about that by that I
mean simply that marriage equality law
certainly this is true if we look at the
line of cases that ends in obergefell
marriage equality law I think is now
recognized and will be talked about as a
branch of family law right but I want to
suggest that marriage equality law can
also be seen as a branch of what might
be called post gay and lesbian sex law
right when we marry the state the law as
men of my generation used to say the law
becomes a kind of top right we want to
be covered by the law right younger
people say well my generation said top
and bottom younger people say dumb and
sub this is going to play wonderfully on
c-span I will see how you write at that
right but I think what animates this is
an imagined desire to be talked to by
the law
she's lived in the bodies of gay men and
lesbians but which exceeds an
instrumental account of the material
benefits of marriage I'm struck for
example by how quickly the argument that
marriage confers eleven hundred or so
benefits that gay men are and and
lesbians are not getting gave way to an
argument about the importance in
Schwarzenegger versus Perry the
California case of feeling married right
feeling in my bones feeling in my body
that I am married now I call it sex law
because I believe that this yearning to
feel married is the site of a certain
kind of embodied pleasure right so I'm
lining up here I'm a good Foucault daeun
bodies and pleasures right so that even
though marriage law is in many ways made
possible by kind of D sexualizing move I
think we need to think about the ways in
which it's still the site for a kind of
afterlife which has to do with desires
and pleasures and bodies at the level of
our collective ideological imaginations
right so it's a fantasy right but the
libidinal economy with if you will of
marriage law and the comparative
historical and critical accounts that
catherine gives us of the
african-american and LBGT campaigns for
marriage equality i think would gain a
lot by really plumbing and engaging in
an extended analysis some of it might be
Aetna graphic of the expressive and
affective dimensions of these two
struggles to win civil marriage and it
would also put us in conversation with
scholars who are working on law and the
emotions or more generally on the ways
in which the law is not only nor always
about the instrumental practical
business of regulation and institutional
design but is also about emotion
imagination and what Raymond Williams
has called the structures of feeling
that underwrite this body of law and
policy
this is particularly important to keep
in mind for a cultural studies approach
that looks at law here the law of
marriage as a cultural form so by
talking about bodies pleasures desire I
think we need to not lose sight of the
ways in which there's a neurotics of at
work in this area of the law and in this
marriage contract which I'm suggesting
the state is inviting us to join there's
a lot more to be said about that but
I'll leave the subject since Marianne is
looking at me anxiously but some right I
have two more panels this is appointed
which I I'm thinking here of the opera
Lulu which I saw last night and and and
and the ways in which Alban Berg the the
composer of this opera just does a a
really brilliant job of focusing on the
compulsory character of marriage is a
moment where Lulu says I think it's who
or at last or next to last husband he
says that's why I married you and Lulu
says but you didn't marry me and her
husband dr. Shuren says then asked then
what did I do
and Lulu says I married you right so
thinking about this is sex law to what
extent has the state married us even as
it is inviting us to think that we are
acting through an autonomy and an agency
which is about self ordering I think
that's an important area for further
investigation the third panel very
briefly is going to be a panel on
marriage and what I like to call the
roots of respectability the ways in
which marriage laws of species of moral
regulation one can compare usefully here
the parallel convergent but also
divergent histories of racial
respectability and homosexual
respectability and the investments all
turned alternately in racial reputation
and moral reputation catherine is
flagged these ideas of maturity the
civilizing process
that marriage represents but the point I
would want to make here is that the
reproductive posts gay virtually sexual
family since the gay lesbian family
raises children and reproduces without
procreation it couldn't be more
respectable right how to have children
without sex that's the story of the new
post gay post sexual family right but
what are the wages of respectability
very quickly three of one respectability
is a regime of self surveillance the
story that Katherine tells in the book
about how blacks reported other blacks
who then got caught up in the machinery
of the criminal law once marriage had
been conferred and they violated the
laws of marriage writ large is a story
about community self surveillance -
respectability um is a kind of death
sentence I might say um the
respectability politics of marriage
equality represent a kind of death
sentence is another image from Lulu for
what the South African judge Albie Sachs
calls the right to be different right
the the ask for formal legal equality
has nothing to do with the right to be
different right
and I I believe that that aspect of it
is an invitation to see marriage
equality as a response or as a an effort
to banish or race the twin stigmas of
AIDS and the age of AIDS and
criminalization that was in the Supreme
Court struck down in Lawrence vs Texas
and it has as Katherine notes and
historical antecedents in the story of
good Blacks policing bad blacks as as
she puts it and I do think that we're
seeing we're going to see what she calls
the afterlife of homophobia continued to
play itself out in this kind of self
surveillance and in for example the the
almost utter absence of interest in the
gay and lesbian community to a whole
range of issues that affect the lives of
gay men and lesbians such as mass
incarceration the death penalty and the
like about which I've written forth and
finally I would like to see a panel at
the conference on wedlock on marriage
law and sexual democracy or the deferral
of sexual democracy about marriage law
to be more precise and neoliberal sexual
politics Catherine writes at one point
in the book it is a curious thing to
pursue a civil rights strategy that
nests a fuller form of public
citizenship within marriage a distinctly
private domain
I think it's curious but it is
completely consistent with the emerging
logics of neoliberal family law right to
the extent that marriage equality law is
a species or branch of neoliberal family
law by privatizing sexual politics and
by socializing that private privilege
through the stigma that attaches to non
normative intimate associations in the
gay and lesbian community the
beneficiaries of marriage equality law
are going to profit from right the
extension by the state of legitimacy to
their relationship which effectively
shuts down a struggle which I certainly
have all my adult life seen myself to be
a part of and another way to put it is
to say that marriage equality D
democratizes sexual politics by nesting
a freedom struggle for the right to
sexual pleasure by nesting a freedom
struggle which in Frederick Jameson's
terms places the question of pleasure as
a political issue right squarely on the
public agenda in a claim for formal
legal
equality right of privatized formal
legal equality yes by nesting this
freedom struggle for a human right to be
different and for a right to sexual
pleasure within a movement for marriage
rights marriage equality effectively
crowds out in Catherine's image certain
forms of democratic invention and
practices of sexual freedom which we
have yet to imagine right so this
closure I think is a price that we have
not even begun really to take the
measure off but I am pleased and it's
proudest punch that my colleague
Catherine Franky's book has given us a
toolkit for thinking through some of the
difficult and intractable problems and
the enormous challenges that those of us
who still believe that there is dignity
to the struggle for sexual liberation
will need in the years to come thank you
very much
[Applause]
since the conference is not yet
scheduled I think we'll take some time
now to discuss these wonderful the book
and these responses I think it's
anybody's fantasy everybody's fantasy to
have such different and rich responses
to anything that one has just published
so I think it's a tribute to this
wonderful book and to our speakers
Katherine would you like to respond to
any of these questions before we open it
up I actually would rather hear
questions and I'll just work my
responses into into what seemed like
answers to your questions but hopefully
also answer your questions so yeah so
the floor is open yes for many years and
now I'm transitioning into becoming an
academic and a lot of your work has been
very helpful in thinking things through
particularly your work professor Moore
and work at UCLA out of the Williams
Institute I wanted to ask you professor
Thomas briefly brought up one word that
was really on my mind hearing you talk
aids which i think is a really big way
to think about what marriage equality
has taken us away from and sort of after
the era of act up
why did marriage equality become the the
issue that now has a lot of gay people
saying we have full equality at the same
time you know the the epidemic has
become really in in the realm of
criminal black sexuality or sort of
thought to be that way and I've
certainly seen that a lot in the state
of Missouri where I've been reporting
and starting to do my research both in
their very strict HIV criminalization
laws or I've been following one case but
also in a realm that gay people I find
have a really no concept of when Mike
Brown was killed just a few days before
he was killed there was a HIV activists
that I work with they were at the the
Canfield apartments doing doing testing
because it's a real microsite of HIV but
it's not really considered you know you
don't see HIV sort of coming to
visibility in that
yet these things are very related and so
I wondered if your book has offered if
you thought about this and if you've
seen HIV as a had my role and why these
movements have become so different I'm
gonna say a little bit and also defer to
my colleagues for their thoughts I was
an HIV discrimination lawyer before I
was an academic so I spent a lot of time
working on HIV related issues before we
had the term AIDS actually to describe
it in the 1980s and so much of that work
both on the professional and on the
personal level was about thinking about
care and who we cared for and who we
should care for and we we thought
kinship very broadly then because of the
discrimination that people who are HIV
positive or experiencing from their
families of origin sometimes their own
partners were we're dying also and so we
saw each other as having a community
responsibility to take care of each
other because there were no other
resources this was during the period of
Reagan and you know horrible
state-sponsored violence against people
who are HIV positive so to go from that
period of sex being encase X which was
really women's sexuality was sort of
invisible so it was gay men's sex as
being toxic and a threat not to mention
perverse and deviant and would kill you
to what we see now where we legally at
least the story we are told in the
marriage equality movement the the the
fantasy is that we only owe legal and
other responsibilities to the people we
marry and not to the larger community of
people that we previously saw as kin and
also that sex is somehow sanitized
within the institution of marriage and
no longer a threat and I thought what
Kendall said about the respectability of
of having children without sex was was
just delightful
it's we're told a very different story
and what I find so remarkable and
reflect on in the book quite a bit is
how successful that rebranding has been
both as a story we tell the outside
world but also a story we've told
ourselves about who we are and who our
families are and who who and how we
should love one another and and there's
something enormous Lee lost I think in
that in that new storytelling and in one
of the chapters where I talk about the
afterlife of home until homophobia I
somewhat ironically but but not entirely
celebrate Anthony Weiner is the new
queer subject you know a man who just
loved sex lots of it
lots of it publicly and the gay
community had nothing to say about sex
for sexist sake when not that long ago
we had a lot to say about promiscuity
sex with blacks of different partners
people you didn't know necessarily and
how to both have sex and take care of
yourself and your partners but we were
speechless really in the face of Anthony
Weiner so I think aids lurks as as as
Kendall mentioned as a kind of fatality
both literally and figuratively of the
marriage equality movement that we don't
speak it anymore and it's it's - it's at
our peril certainly collect a couple of
questions and then but really could you
please just have a question and not a
lengthy comment yes
I'm looking forward to reading the book
thank you so much I can say clearly see
what you're talking about
in terms of the strategy the safe
strategy taken and then the road not
taken' so I guess my question is in
terms of legal strategy and marriage in
equality what does what would the road
not taken' and have looked like in your
the better road not taken' have looked
like and what can we retrieve from that
road that was not taken two quick things
to say about that we worked very hard on
domestic partnership civil union laws
forms of recognition so that we had a
range of ways to perhaps create some
legal or financial security for our non
marital relationships and what was nice
about domestic partnerships and civil
unions is that they they allowed you
some room to innovate and didn't invite
the state into without setting the terms
of what your relationship was and then
by and large the gay community has
dropped defending those alternative
institutions and in fact part of their
legal strategy was to vilify them as
second-class status in order to win
marriage rights and I don't think we
needed to say then in order to say that
the state refusing to recognize same-sex
couples as entitled to marriage is a
constitutional problem we could have
both so walking and chewing gum I think
was something that we that we didn't do
and we could have the other road not
taken' is that we could have won the
right to marry in a different way
without leading with dignity we could
have led the argument the claim with
something that looked more like equality
on the level of excluding same-sex
couples from marriage is a form of
state-sponsored homophobia or
heterosexism or hatred towards gay
people just as in loving versus Virginia
the Supreme Court said that laws that
don't allow white people or the
criminalize white people who marry
people of a different sex is a form of
white supremacy I mean that's a powerful
claim
it's a powerful argument from the
Supreme Court that we've never heard
again but we could have borrowed the
power of what the law does and what
motivates the law in the marriage
equality fight but we didn't instead we
made a claim that that that some
same-sex couples should be blessed by
the institution of marriage in order to
dignify or recognize their dignity and
and in part that was a an appeal to
Justice Kennedy who is middle whose
middle name is dignity I saw something
on line today that said maybe his a take
on dignity will also help the abortion
cases that are before the court this
term I think absolutely not absolutely
not I think there's something
undignified about getting pregnant and
wanting to wanted to terminate that
pregnancy or to have the power yourself
to make that decision that's very
different from the kinds of claims that
were made or the arguments that were
made in the marriage equality cases but
here I am answering the questions and
you want to do accumulate a few that's
okay
maybe we'll collect three questions and
then do some final remarks
thanks so much it's been amazing so so
far we've kind of limited our commentary
to domestic politics in the marriage
equality movement as it's happened in
the West or at least the US but of
course we know that marriage equality
has been globalized and transnational
eyes not only through the advancement of
marriage equality but also through the
specter of same-sex marriage and things
like this same sex marriage prohibition
bill in Nigeria which kind of relates
not only to an egg respectability
politics but also necro politics so we
saw that in the last couple of weeks the
USD asylum-seekers LGBT asylum seekers
in the US could now apply to have their
partners come to us only if they had not
been able to get married in their native
countries if only if they had only if
they'd have been together and not been
able to get married had not described
for marriage so I'm curious if you could
comment on how the marriage equality
movement affects not only respectability
but also disposability of queer bodies
well that's a that's a great question I
think if you will accept the proposition
which I hope you will that the gains of
marriage equality not just United States
but globally have been taking place
within the shadow of neoliberal
capitalism
and the privatization of dependency that
the repudiation of the social welfare
state not that we ever had one here but
that the repudiation of the social
welfare state in other parts of the
world that is going on has represented
then I think what we can say about that
specific policy is that as a strategy as
a regulatory strategy it's about the
distribution of these now privatized
dependencies right and so if you can't
get married in the country from which
your partner comes then we will allow
you to get married here so it's a
question really about the allocation of
this now totally privatized right to be
dependent through the institution of
marriage and this relates to the
question that Professor Russell raised I
was involved in 2006 I believe with the
group of activists from a variety of
different parts of civil society who
produced a document over the course of a
weekend called beyond gay marriage and
the goal there was to try to defend not
only the plural forms of kinship and
intimate Association that gay men
lesbians and queers had developed in the
absence of a right to civil marriage but
also to be true to the larger vision of
the gay lesbian struggle as they
struggle for sexual liberation I would
have added in my formal remarks for all
people right that's why it's a question
about sexual democracy writ large and so
I think the the challenge
at the level of its broad orientation
with respect to questions of policy is
to try to fashion ways in which we can
drive a wedge between this idea that of
that that access to social benefit
should be contingent on and hinge on
whether or not you're married right that
relationships of dependency ought to be
governed by what our former colleague
Martha Fineman calls the sexual family
right that is the root of the problem
but it's it's perfectly Arkan
sistent with the logic of neoliberal
capital and the contract into which
those persons who get married whatever
their sexual orientation belong
alongside that though we're also seeing
what I think might be called as the
emergence of a new sexual orientation
right you have homo normativity and you
have heterosexual normativity right
marriage the alignment of the normative
I might say the normal with marital
status whether you're gay or lesbian or
heterosexual I think is a moment of
sexual realignment which in many ways
are corresponds to the moments of racial
realignment that we've seen in the age
of neoliberalism so I I think it's it's
a it's a difficult but important
question that you ask but we have to see
the connections between the national the
transnational and global capital under
neoliberalism I can add one thing one of
the chapters in the book in the
historical section talks about why
northern soldiers or missionaries are a
benevolent others were forcing freely
newly free people to marry and it was
explicitly in order to privatize
dependency they explicitly said we don't
want to pay for these poor women and
children we'd like to have the men serve
in the military and or be sharecroppers
but we want the men to be responsible
for the dependency needs of their kids
it's just Martha Fineman all the way
down in the work that she's done in
thinking the dependency and the
privatization of it into the family we
don't say it as explicitly today but
they said it very honestly then and I
think there's a lesson in that
comparison the one other thing I want to
mention about about that dependency is
that one of the last chapter in the book
looks at the gendering of LGBT or of
same-sex couples through the process of
divorce and what what what judges are
doing in divorce court or in Family
Court when same-sex couples come to them
two for two divorce are turning lesbians
into husbands and gay men into wives in
many contexts because all those judges
know are heterosexual relationships by
you know by law they've never had
same-sex couples before them and the
rules of divorce assume gender
inequality to echo something that minion
said earlier and the courts don't know
how to see families that think
responsibility and dependency
differently than a deeply gendered form
now feminists have worked hard to change
marriage law in order to account for
gender disadvantage and heterosexual
relationships but how those rules get
picked up and applied to same-sex
relationships when they go through
divorce it's shocking to some same-sex
couples who thought they had a different
deal than what marriage law entails and
so the the one partner becomes the
husband and the other partner becomes
the wife because that's all that those
courts know-how or those judges know how
to render legible to them and then you
get plunked into slots in marriage law
or divorce law does its work and it's
about a neoliberal idea of the family
that is I think we'll see whether we're
able to blow that institution up I don't
know I hope you're right
yeah I'm housebroken then we're out of
time
can we take 10 more minutes or what's
people willing to we have a reception we
have book sales let's take one more
question let's take one more question
yes
you mentioned at the beginning of your
talk with James discipline and punish I
just think you keep going just back away
tons of mics yes speak okay you
mentioned the terms discipline and
punish with regard to the way that
marriage has operated as what Biko might
see as a normalizing judgment which
enterprise it interpolates and
formalizes and legitimate subjects into
a realm of cultural and certainly legal
intelligibility so then if in fukui in
terms discipline aims to not only let
the state wield power more effectively
but also produce docile bodies that
operate more efficient efficiently and
with more attitude than what in your
formulation of marriage does does
marriage equality or marriage itself as
a structure on seek to amplify in terms
of the capacity of its subjects that's
such a sophisticated question do i I
don't want to dominate too much anymore
than I already have do any of the rest
of you want your book well I would agree
with some of the comments of Professor
Thomas that we have a neoliberal
economic project at stake that many of
the advocates of same-sex marriage are
completely signed up for there are they
they want access to the kinds of
privileges and benefits that that are
get distributed rightly or wrongly but
get distributed through the institution
of marriage if we had universal or
single-payer health care wouldn't matter
that you were married to someone who had
a good job and had health insurance if
we had real pensions or real retirements
then it wouldn't matter so much whether
you could inherit your partner's Social
Security you know etc etc so so I do
think that there is a larger project at
stake here that surrendering to the
discipline of marriage rather
unthinkingly
collaborates with that said you've given
me the opportunity to tell you about the
appendix to the book
which is a program a progressive call of
action from married queers so those of
you and there are many who have married
while kind of holding your nose because
your lawyer or your accountant or others
said you're just an idiot not to do it
you can still be a good person in my
view and I give you a eight-point agenda
for how to remain faithful to a critique
of neoliberalism how not to collaborate
in the the other ring of unmarried
people and how to think of
responsibilities to one another more
broadly than the neoliberal model
certainly anticipates and requires so
turn to page 233 turn this into Flyers
that you will put around your workplaces
and dorms but I have it I have a
manifesto for how you can marry and
still be a progressive person and you
will not go to hell necessarily honest
have-your-cake- and-eat-it-too I don't
know if we have cake but I think we have
some wine and cheese and in anticipation
of the conference that Kendall outlined
for us I'd like to thank you all and
thank you all for coming thank you
please say please buy the book Katherine
will sign it for you
oh thank you so much yeah